salut mercredi 6 heures ça c'est plutôt
une intro facile du coup à faire est
vrai en plus vous vous souvenez de ce
casse tête que j'avais adoré binaire oui
qui était extrêmement compliqué à
réaliser
il y avait quatre sur quatre il fallait
sortir accroché extrait de ce moment lui
doit être en bas maintenant ok donc
maintenant pour pouvoir le tir et à fond
comme je veux il faut que 800 au 808
soins ou figurez vous qu'ils ont sorti
une version ultime de ça alors que lui
était déjà bien galère alors j'ai cassé
leur tirelire un je crois qu'il a 300 $
un truc comme ça je vous mets le lien
dans la description mais eux ne
l'achetez que si vraiment votre vie en
dépend en fait
apparemment ma vie en dépendait puisque
je les prie je regrette le hic
je regrette déjà il fait donc dix
langues est sur dix langues est il y à
une bille ici cette bille
notre but est de l'emmener ici comme
binaire il n'y a pas de choses cachées
un tout et à vue et puis tu as deviné
est qui était embêtant c'étaient les
cases qui était un petit peu en s1 je me
suis un bien voilà donc on a que de ça
et pas dans le même sens tu vois la
salle terme ça est très très sympathique
qu'elle j'ai prévu quelques accessoires
un de prédilection j'ai prévu de ne pas
trop discuté avec vous aujourd'hui est
ce que vu ma mort en fait j'ai même
hésité à le faire en live mais je me
suis un live de 17 heures c'est
peut-être un peu long
[Musique]
donc à part en tant qu'élément boucle à
ce moment précis mon but c'est vrai que
lui soient poussés ainsi que lui ok donc
lui pour le pousser non il faut déjà que
je crie je suis quand même content lui
pour le pousser qu'est ce qui bloque lui
devrait être
il devrait pas être bloqués là donc il
faut que je pousse lui mais lui pour le
pousser il faut que lui enfin comment
sais tu commences grave quoi voilà là là
là je crois qu'il faut quand même que je
fasse ça ça ça ça parce que je voulais
pousser lui lui comme je pouvais pas le
pousser fallait d'abord que je fasse ça
pour continuer à le descendre il faut
quand même que je fasse ça et alors du
coup faut que je fasse ça sans oublier
que je veux vraiment que lui décembre
donc il faut que je fasse ça donc là je
peux pas encore poussé parce que lui il
faut qu ils remontent pour le remonter
je fais ça du coup je fais ça du coup
j'ai commencé à le pousser pour
continuer à le penser il faut que lui
descendent donc il faut que lui remonte
pour remonter il faut que les fiches de
est là mais pour continuer à mettre là
faut que lui je leur demande donc lui
l'âge nettement je peux pousser donc lui
je peux leur monte donc lui je peux le
descendre à mort mais il ya d'autres
choses qui bloque
il ya lui qui bloque donc lui il faut
que je puisse le descendant pour le
descendre
il faut que miss wade sans table pour
qu'ils soient des 100 da ble il faut que
je le mette lui l'a donc pour le maître
lui là il faut que la faut que je
commence à prendre des repères mon but
c'est de descendre lui lui lui lui on
veut qu'ils descendent
oh c'est pas mal ça même décrit donc
pour quantic qui continuent à descendre
faut que lui il aille il soit bien à
droite là qu'ils soient bien à droite
donc pour qu'il soit bien comment je
fais comment je fais qu'est ce qui
bloque lui bloque lui il me bloque donc
je le manque et lui me bloque aussi donc
faut que je le descendre mais pour le
descendre
oh lalalalalalalalala lui mais qui crée
ça en vrai qui a taillé un bois qui est
un peu pété est ce qu'on voit là que le
bout de bois et les pet est en deuil
mais regardez regardez là le bout de
bois s'est scindé comme ça un an qu tu
es trop chiant non non oui crack tac tac
tac tac tac très bien ce petit système
de post it au lit car je viens de dire
quoi très bien ce petit site et de post
it audika exactement correct
qu'est ce qu'on voulait faire au départ
on voulait que tout c'est lui donc lui
il faut lequel j'arrive à le remonter
par contre ça ça ça ça ça ça peut-être
ça et ensuite ça et je gagne un grand
pour gagner le deuxième cran quand
celle-ci kabylie est resté là moi je ne
sais pas non plus ça c'est bizarre ça
quand même cette histoire débile verra
ça tout à fait par doute alors je ne te
sens pas impliqué sous prétexte que la
vidéo fasse cette heure logique
j'aimerais que tu regardes le cadre en
permanence j'aimerais que tu sois dans
leur pâtit pourquoi tu regarde des
vidéos sur youtube en attendant pourquoi
sur youtube en top tendance on trouve
des trucs de slim ou de slime je n'aime
pas comment 10 d'enfants bleu jaune et
en rend cent sont d'un truc asiatiques
avec un mec a des mains de mecs de 70
ans et qui fait ce blu qui est l'eau
pourquoi loïc
[Musique]
bernard tant de questions à laquelle
nous trouverons la réponse dans ce casse
tête donc lui les applications sont
terribles je me dis tiens lui faut que
je le pousse donc lui faut qu'ils sont
au louis en bas et lui en bas je veux
qu'ils aient sur l'étroit ici que ce
soit ba ba oh ça c'est mon but quoi
c'est le but de ma vie aujourd'hui que
baba au foyer m'avoir et bien non tu ne
m'as jamais ouais ouais
aie aie je sais plus où j'en suis vous
allez bien mais l'afrique était alors
celui que je voulais mettre en haut il
est en haut
c'est comme ça peut-être qu'il est aussi
en bas ce qui veut dire je voulais bas
haut bas bas au sur la troisième tranche
j'ai bien babaus donc je peux pousser
comme ceci mais elle réalise et la
connexion tant attendu que j'ai vu dans
les commentaires nombreuses fois où vous
vous mettiez choc dans la connexion ou
et cette connexion bon bien la connexion
est présente par contre la bille n'est
pas présente
thaler a été présent pourquoi ne l'est
plus alors attendez j'ai c'est un truc
oui je les fais délicatement par ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon un
retournement qualitatif je mets une
petite cale pour garder une pente
descendante principe qu'elle abandonnait
sa part sur une réussite là qui s'est
passé c'est que tout débute cette vidéo
la vie était ici on l'a fait passer là
maintenant on a fait passer la donc le
secret le secret c'est quoi ces 42
l'autre secret c'est quoi c'est que je
vais vous récompenser ceux qui regardent
cette vidéo les salières et les pauvres
y hier dans la cuisine
de mon livre de chasse au trésor c'est
du morse voilà je craque complètement je
largue et des indices pour ceux qui
osent suivre cette vidéo en entier je
peux qui m'a regardé un peu le secret
c'est quoi c'est de créer des petites
connexions comme ceci la différence avec
l'autre fois c'est le système mais
familier le toit j'avais mis déjà 20
minutes à comprendre les principes de
l'imbrication et puis la différence
c'est que je me suis équipé c'est pas un
placement de produit pour post it
parce que quand tu parles à tes mains
derrière la caméra les gens te voient
pas louis mais les mains devant la
camomille ressentent
tu crois vous ressentez loïc parce que
vous ressentez le hic
alors on fait quoi on pousse très fort
et ça a fait crac et sa basse ce que
sévissent ces davis sur sa tribu pour ta
santé mentale ce frigo à je pousse ainsi
je fais une petite flèche en haut je
vais ouvrir une chaîne pour vous
apprendre à faire des flèches sur les
post it comment s'appellera cette chaîne
s'appelle fabien euros fabien perrot ok
vous pouvez le site mast post-it fabien
arrow post-it master exactement où je
vous apprends ma technique pour faire en
dia gouaille attention des flèches sur
des petits morceaux de post it et lui
fonctions en eau donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut que je me retape tout parcours
c'est d'un chiant ce castel [ __ ] je
dépensais 300 boules pour salonique ou
sérieux je veux descendre ça pour le
descendre lui bloque toujours parce que
on a envie de quoi on a envie de pisser
encore un petit peu pour le pis et il
faudrait descendre 8
j'appelle truc chez plus pourquoi lui qu
dolly la brebis la rhinite et je veux
descendre lee ainsi il indique mme à
fléchettes ainsi lui il faut point le
pousser et pour le pousser il faut que
lui soient punissables et les pêcheurs
qu'en plus ils sont construits
s'assurant un logiciel
ils ont même pas cherché à réfléchir
sont juste dit mr on va au moins en
vendre un gars au lit car qui va
l'acheter c'est sûr du coup on le met à
300 dollars du canada je les fais venir
donc j'ai payé 60 dollars de taxes que
j'avais pas du tout prévu donc partager
cette vidéo qu'on regarde et je vais
être des pubs régulièrement regarder les
il faut tellement rentabiliser sa bombe
[Applaudissements]
et avec le big boi là qui déconne je
peux dire que je n'ai amusé comme un
petit fou et c'est ça qu'on veut faire
c'est ce à quoi un cliché n'est pas
d'accord on pousse lui même boutboul et
des peules et bien nous saouler je suis
d'accord d'un tournevis
non on peut pas sa fille j ai dit que tu
es le week-end je ne sais pas si tu peux
faire des zooms et la caméra mais
regardez comment je galère avec ce bout
de bois
parce que quand il se met en travers
mais forcément je préoccupe ici
j'ai fait ce soir le finir jusqu à cause
de ça on est sérieux qu'est ce qu'on
veut on veut qu lui il soit en bas pour
que lui il soit adroit vraiment regarder
les tutos parce que là moi j'ai pas le
temps de vous expliquer les post it et
on rigole un moment donné je me souviens
je rigolais trop quoi aulas lots de bois
qui ont fait n'importe quoi il ya des
fois juste il me fait confiance à mon
instinct
parce que je sais plus ce que je fais et
je sais qu'il peut faire elle est allée
au bout de voix qui l'école et donc il
faut remonter scié mais jean-jacques tu
te moquer de moi jean jacques parce que
qu'est ce que je voulais 4e je passerai
mes petites notes cela va bien il nous
manque c'est de la poésie est holla
holla catal américain ncaa
sayyed saïd akretche aucun pilote n'a de
pacho un gars je veux résoudre un casse
tête
aujourd'hui ce mercredi à 6 heures du
matin je vous le ferai gagner sur
instagram parce que je ne veux plus le
voir après et je ne veux aucun
commentaire de will cost est réellement
finie que quand le roi mermet le toit
est en faute
tak tak
merci de suivre du coup pour monter lui
a le on se concentre un petit peu c'est
c'la là avoue jean-pierre bah oui j'ai
des problèmes de fenêtres à l'épreuve
dette nette reste élevée quand l'avion
se trouve sur la ligne bourg j'aurais
voulu à elle annulé ce que je voulais
faire mais tu le vois tu le vois mais
regarde le losc
je veux que tu viens de le voir soi-même
je veux que tu constates je veux que tu
me dises mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel la merde à moi je serais toi d'en
abandonner à tétouan mais tais toi mais
tu es toi je rêve d'abord donné et j'ai
un côté psychorigide qui m'en empêche
le hic je prends une décision que je
pète ce bout de bois c'est infaisable
je vais pas du tout touché au casse-tête
pas dû toucher la vie je vais juste viré
ce bout de bois c'est infernal doit
cette reprise de tête vous rendez pas
compte le black depuis tout à l'heure
mais c'est déjà ça me coupe les actions
chez en train de forcer sur truc à
morges le pt puisque m moi je peux
passer et c'est vraiment sur la case qui
sert à tout c'est on va rire c'est dans
le truc c'est la 0 / 0 quoi c'est celle
dans toutes les actions dépendent en
permanence c'est pas la bonne mais pas
la bonne mais c'est la bonne marche pas
pourquoi j'ai pas fait ça des débuts
sans déconner parce que faut surtout par
bouger les languettes du coup tu nous as
fier ok ensuite donc je lui en bas mais
lui ont fait perdre comme un bon gros on
veut comme on le veut pour le verrou lui
il est en bas ça va je tiens pékin oui
c'est important d'être le père fouras
mon premier herlaut mon deuxième est
relou aussi mon troisième un petit peu
chiant quand même mon tout est
exactement ce casse-tête une culture
locale film salonique le cul du cul
non mais c'est moi non plus je cherche
en studio des télés les délais du ces
milana je crois pas que son minalogic ce
seigneur a annoncé dans shrek allait
voir qu'il l'avait dans les commentaires
soyez pas mytho nous intervenons mito là
comme ça elle vient se présenter ici
en faisant ce déplacement donc attention
on fait la bascule
vas-y bascule avec délicatesse et
précision je la ramène comme ceux ci
elle est passée elle est vraiment en
quatrième présentation de cinquième fois
et ça fait jean jacques
c'est comme ça que ça marche bien avec
ma petite réparation de tout à l'heure
il se peut que d'une manière assez
formidable
je puisse passer directement sous-indice
bois avec amour journaux moi je
n'utiliserai jamais cette astuce
regardez moi bien dans les yeux
j'aime le voilà les amis je viens de
rentrer sans lui pour sécuriser la vie
qui est dans le cas tant présentation du
en clair on est à mi chemin de ce casse
tête après un moment donné je crois
qu'il faut penser à la santé mentale non
pas de moi parce que moi je suis capable
dire 3,1 85e 3 1 4 1 5 2 des 6 559 êtes
le soir 2 3 ghz 4 6 2 6 4 3 litres de
7,9 5,02 et cetera et cetera sept et
huit ans qui atteint 9,7 un bond est
supérieur aux 6 9 7 3 7 5 1 0 bon bref
ça va santé mentale
nous on avait fait je me souviens un
dîner pour le dire au revoir
on l'a fait une fois un pot de départ
par contre maintenant c'est là leur tube
je ne tremble pas cessé de me dire je
pense à leur propre santé mentale et je
me dis si on fait tout dans un épisode
il est possible
message tu vois non franchement j'espère
que la semaine prochaine sera un truc
plus simples avec des chiffres et tout
ça parce que vraiment un moment donné on
se faire d'épisodes de m'en laisse
passer un petit peu de temps comme celle
sécurisé ça ne bougera plus je gardais
mes notes parce que elles sont je crois
essentiel je me retrouverais extrêmement
bien n'oublie pas que je vous fait
gagner ce casse-tête sur instagram mais
quand je leur ai fini parce que sinon le
ce nul a casté d'une valeur de 7
milliards d'euros
et vous pouvez vous abonner en cliquant
là vous pouvez regarder une vidéo de
lapin qui est pas du tout sur ma chaîne
que je vous met là je trouve une vidéo
de lapin que je vous mettrais on va
propulser une chaîne de lapin parce que
ça suffit
ici cette vidéo c'est l'algorithme qui
choisit et moi je vais me mettre à pouce
en l'air et je vous embrasse
salut